how much detail do you pay toward
background players you know solos oh the
most interesting the most because I feel
that so much attention anybody can get
the three or four lead characters right
because you spend so much time on them
and and I feel that it's the background
that and the the background the cars the
horses or whatever carriages that really
sell the period it's that big background
out there if it looks really really real
then you have your you have the setting
the the whole backdrop for the painting
that you're going to do your main
portraits within and I always say that
the background is the most important
part of the movie to me getting it right
like all the natives in this movie all
the background French trappers all the
trappers that don't have speaking roles
in the movie that are stuntmen or are
just part of the camp or part of the
entourage of trappers I think that's
what really really sells the close-ups
of your main cast when you begin a
production how many times do you read
the script and well I go by the day
Edith Head rule seven times before you
start don't even make one costume or do
one drawing - you've read the script
seven times because she said then you
know all your characters inside out and
you just take me shopping in the period
you